bugün benim konuşmamın teması bağlantı
Ben hayatta küçük ya da büyük canlı ya
da cansız her şeyin arasında bir
bağlantı olduğuna inananlardan buna
benim inanmam bir şey ifade etmiyor
Aslında bu Akademik olarak da üzerinde
bilimsel olarak çalışılan bir konu Hatta
Bahçeşehir Üniversitesi Tıp Fakültesi
dekana Profesör Doktor Türker Kılıç
hocamız var Bu konuyla alakalı
çalışmalar var hatta kitabı var
bağlantısal bütünselliğin diye
evrenin tamamen bir bağlantı üzerine
kurulmuş bir matematiğinin olduğuna
inanıyor ve bunun üzerinde çalışmalar
gerçekleştiriyor bir yerlerde denk
gelirseniz dinlemenizi tavsiye ederim
Kendinize iyi bakın ve ben ondan yapay
zekayı canlı şekilde dinledim bir Yapay
Zeka dediğimiz olay zaten beynin taklit
edil
mesi ve Afrika'da kanat Çırpan bir
kelebek Amerika'da bir fırtınaya sebep
olabilirdi Şimdi biz biliyoruz ki bir
kelebek bırakın bir fırtına çıkarmayı
bir yelpaze etmesi bile yapamaz aslında
ama onunla bağlantılı o kadar küçük
olaylar var ki neticesi çok çok büyük
etkiler ortaya çıkarabiliyor ve Bizim
hayatımız da böyle Aslında dedim ya
bağlantı hayatımıza girip çıkan ve bizim
önemsiz olarak gördüğümüz şeyler aslında
bizim geleceğimizi şekillendiriyor
olabilirler Dolayısıyla bize düşen yine
söylüyorum kendimizi keşfetmek bu
dönemde Şimdi bu fotoğrafta benim
yaklaşık 20 sene önceki halimi
görüyorsunuz Gördüğünüz üzere daha genç
ve aza yani öğrenciyim o zamanlar ben
Erciyes Üniversitesi bilgisayar
mühendisliği bölümü mezunu 99 yılında
üniversiteyi kazandım ve bilgisayar
mühendisliği bölümünü tercih ettim bu
bölümün tercih etme ile alakalı emin
olun Bunu neden yaptığıma dair hiçbir
fikrim yok çünkü hayatında hiç
bilgisayar olmamış bir insan olarak
konuşuyorum Bilgisayar kullanmayı
Bilmeden ve puanım da fena değildi o
zaman ilk 7.000'e girmişti o zaman
Bilgisayar Mühendisliği bölümlerinin
puanları yüksekti Eee Ama ne hikmetse
ben bilgisayar mühendisliği yazdım Hani
Tıp gibi vesaire başka bölümleri aslında
girebilecekken
Burada da
tabii üniversite Bilgisayar Mühendisliği
bölümüne Bu arada 77.000'e girdim ama 40
kişilik ölüme 39 sıradan ancak girebilir
sizler gibi zehir gibi adamlar vardı
benim için de tabi hepsi teknik liseden
vesaireden geliyorlar Eee kodlama
altyapılar var vesaire şimdi tahtada
belki bilgiler arkadaşlarımız bilirler
veri yapılan algoritmalar dersi var İyi
eşittir iyi artı bir yazıyor bak işte
burada YSK matematik ile gelmişti bir
değişken kendinin bir fazlasına nasıl
eşit olabilirdi kafanda Bunu
sorguluyorsun daha oradasın yanındaki
Adam az kaldı Yılan oyunu yazıyor böyle
bir ortamak için
tabi bunun sonuçları biraz kötü oldu ilk
dönemin Daha doğrusu 1 sınıfın sonunda 9
tane zayıf okula uyum sağlayamayan bir
öğrenci ve kendi kendine şunu sorgulayan
bir adam Ben yanlış bölümü seçtim Yol
yakınken başka türlü hayatı nasıl
yönlendirebilirim ne yapabilirim fikrimi
nasıl değiştirebilirim bunun üstüne
yoğunlaşıyorum Tam o sırada
bir yarışma düzenleniyor Microsoft'un
ilk defa düzenlediği bir yarışma
üniversiteler arası proje yarışması
Bilgisayar Mühendisliği bölümlerinde
Katılıyor Bizim bir arkadaş grubu da o
yarışmaya katılıyorlar
beni davet ettiler ekibe dedim ki ben
yazılım beceremiyorum ki abi Beni niye
davet ediyorsunuz olsun Sen de gel dedim
Tamam dedim Bir şansımızı deneyelim
birincisi yazılım yapmayı beceremiyorum
ikincisi sevmiyorum kendimle alakalı
tespitim bu fakat orada şunu gördü bir
gerçeğin ne olduğu nerede olduğuyla çok
Aslında Göreceli bir kavram var Ben
kendimce hem yazılım yapmayı hem yazılım
geliştirmeyi sevmediğimi becer
emedim becerebildiğimi fark ettim sonra
ne olur biliyor musunuz 3 aylık bir
zaman geliştirme zaman içerisinde ki
bana da aslında çok ciddi bir görev
verdiler o görevleri yerine getirdi
Biz o yarışmada Türkiye üçüncüsü olduk
96 tane projenin içerisinde bir sürü
Kallavi üniversitenin katıldığı Bir
yarışmada Türkiye üçüncüsü olduk benim
hayatımın en önemli kırılma noktasıdır
Çünkü artık yazılım yapmayı
becerebildiğini Hatta daha da kıymetlisi
bu işi sevdiğimi fark ettim
ve bundan sonra kendime söylediğim şey
Ömer tam da olmak istediğin yerdesin
hayatına Bundan sonra buradan
bir sevmeye başladıktan sonra başka
yarışmalara da geliyorsunuz başka
kendinizi geliştirecek işlerde
yapıyorsunuz ve artık belli bir noktaya
geldim zayıflarımı toparladım vesaire
mitozofun bir programı daha var yaz
okulu programı her sene Bilgisayar
Mühendisliği bölümlerinden birer tane
öğrenciyi alıp bir ay boyunca çok
kıymetli eğitmenlerden eğitim alıyorlar
ona başvurdum Tabii bir sürü insan
başvurdu ama benim kabul ettiler neden
bu yarışmada elde ettiğim derece Onun
için referans oldu
sonra okul bitti mezun oluyorum iş
başvurusu yapıyorum Benim Memleketim
Kayseri'nin en büyük firması İstikbal
Mobilya herkes Oraya girmeye çalışıyor O
zamanlar iş başvurusu yap çok katı
kuralları var Bu arada askerliğini
yapmamış kişiyi kesinlikle işe
almıyorlar iş başvurusunda bulundum
yarışmada aldığım derece üstüne
Microsoft Yaz okulunda aldığım sağlam
eğitim Benim askerlik şartını
esnetmelerine vesile oldu ve cuma günü
okul kapandı Pazartesi günü işe başladım
Burada yaklaşık 8 yıl boyunca çalıştım
ve çok şey öğrendim Zira Burası çok
büyük bir fabrika ve çok büyük hareket
var orada o kadar veriyi işleyebilmek
yönetebilmek sizi ister istemez bu
konuda uzman bile haline getiriyor 8 yıl
boyunca çalıştım
daha sonra şimdiki İş yerim olan ısıtsan
şirketinin bir
tekne ama bizim gibi insanlara
baktığımız zaman belli bir noktadan
sonra hayatında daha farklı rutinden
farklı şeyler yapma ihtiyacı doğuyor
bunlara mesela
ben böyle bir şey yapmadım bir gün bir
arkadaşım Erciyes Üniversitesi'ndeki
akademisyenler arkadaşım bana şöyle bir
teklifte bulundu ya adamlar dediler Sen
pratik bilgilerinden bir faydalansak
okula gelsen bizim böyle bir
öğrencilerine Sen ders versen
işte haftada 4 saat yeterli Peki dedim
bu arada Bunun maddi bir karşılığı yok
deneyelim kendime şöyle bir misyon
biçtim Ömer sen madem burada ders
vereceksin Özel sektör
ün için akademinin içinden geliyorsun
buradan Mezun oldun Bu çocukların ne
eksiğinin olduğunu biliyorsun arada
kendine bir aracı
O zaman bu pratik bilgi işini çözmek
sana kaldı kurallar koyun benim dersimde
slayt yok tahta yok Not tutmak yok benim
dersimde full uygulamalı ders seçeceğim
ve bu uygulama interaktif olmak zorunda
yani uygulamayı sadece benim yapıp
gitmem değil çocukların da yapması lazım
kurallar koyduk vize itinayla ortadan
kaldırdım tamamen uygulamalarını
ödevinden her hafta yaptığımız
uygulamayı ödev olarak verdim ve onlara
da yaptı sonra tabii not tutmak vesaire
olmadığı için bu anlatılan şeyler
unutuluyor hocam Biz bunu unutuyoruz
dediklerinde o zaman dedim ki ben
bunlarla alakalı ders kaydını ekran
kaydını alalım ve YouTube'daki kanal
açalım oraya atalım Siz de oradan tekrar
bunu yaptık ve YouTube'da bir kanal
açtık Tabii YouTube çok ilginç bir mecra
YouTube'da public bir ortam olduğu için
burada başkaları da sizi buluyor yani o
kapalı devre ortamına çıkıyorsunuz zaten
insanların sizi takip ettiği bir yer
haline geliyor burası işte yorumlar
takip edenler falan ben biraz daha
Kendime çeki düzen vermeye başladım
Konuşurken daha az öksürüyorum daha
kaliteli mikrofon kullanıyorum falan
derken kendi çapında böyle bir
YouTube'da eğitim hazırlayan bir adam
haline dönüştürdüm tabi YouTube çok
kıymetli bir mecra olduğu için ne oldu
biliyor musunuz Bir gün bir mesaj aldım
Ömer Bey biz sizin YouTube'daki
videolarınızı izledik Ee bize eğitim
hazırlar mısınız diyen kim o kurucusu
Türk olan bir de Türkiye
gündemi Türkiye'den Bana Eren var ya
eğitim hazırlamak için talep geldi benim
uzmanlık alanda microsoftaya sipariş
veri tabanı ve merak ettim hazırladık
artık ekrana karşı falan da rahatlıkla
konuşabiliyorum
büyük bir özgüvenle bir eğitim
hazırladım yaklaşıyor yayını aldım
ekranın gözüne bakıyorum Özgüven Tamam
ne kadar satacak birinci gün baktım
satış
ikinci gün satış
üçüncü gün 0
Ömer Tamam buraya kadar yani artık
yapman gereken normal hayatına devam
etmek bu eğitmenlik işi bir yere kadar
sen fazla Havaya girdin diye kendime
telkinde bulundum sonra 4 gün bir kişi
aldı
sonrasında şu anda dünyanın 105 farklı
ülkesinden 42 binden fazla tekil
öğrencinin aldığı 6 tane Rus yaylada iki
tanesi de şu anda kategorisinin en çok
satan etiketini Hala kendi üzerinde
taşıyor nereden nereye geliyor
tabi
Bir de çok kuvvetli bir mecra gerçekten
artık tanığı da oluyorsunuz Google'da
İşte benim alanım olan esmer
yazdığınızda ilk ben çıkıyorum falan
Sonra
şöyle bir harita var Şunu göstermek
istiyorum
tam projeksiyondan tam seçilmiyor ama
Dünya üzerinde benim öğrencilerimin
olduğu harita çok ilginç haritada adının
yerini gösteremeyeceğim ülkelerden
öğrenciler var hani para bu adam
kolombiya'da meksika'dan 21 tane öğrenci
varmış mesela gerçekten çok gurur verici
bir durum yani oturduğun yerde bunu
görüyor olmak ve bir Fotoğraf fotoğrafta
sol tarafta
vitamini kurucusu yanında da direkt
kokari demin şu an diğer tarafında da
direkt kokarıyla benim beraber Çekilmiş
olduğum bir fotoğrafa Ee üç buçuk milyar
dolarlık bir şirket yok Aslında onunla
alakalı çok güzel bir anlamı var ama
bugün burada Onu anlatmaya zamanımız
yetmeyecek Eee böyle güzel bir şey
Tabii bunlar işin biraz ticari tarafları
ama sadece ticari taraflarıyla
ilgilenmiyoruz Bununla birlikte gönüllü
olarak yaptığımız birçok şey var ben Bu
zamana kadar 40'tan fazla üniversiteye
gittim birçoğuna birden fazla
workshoplar canlı yayınlar konferanslar
Seminerler ve bir sürü etkinlikte
bulunduk tabi birileri sanıyorum bunun
dikkatini çekmiş olmalı ki Microsoft'un
bir programı var ödül programı yani
Türkçesi En değerli profesyonel
Microsoft'un top sektöre ve topluluklara
gönüllü katkı sağlayan ayeti
profesyonellerini vermiş olduğu bir ödül
bu anlat bunu böyle tanımlıyorlar 2020
yılında Ben Ee bu ödüller yapıyoruz bu
benim için çok kıymetli Zira tüm dünyada
şu anda sadece 3 bin tane yemek var
Türkiye'de 21 tane örnek var benim
kategorim olan zaten platform
kategorisinde 3 saniye var şu an biriyle
karşınızda duruyor Gerçekten bu benim
için çok büyük bir Onur bu şekilde
Microsoft'un Web sayfasında
isminizi biyografinizin oluyor olması
gerçekten çok büyük bir gurur
ve
şöyle demin dedim ya bağlantı bir
düşünün Ne vardı ilk başta umutsuz bir
öğrenci Bu arada sosyal etkinliklerden
başka bir görüntü daha
ne vardı umutsuz bir öğrenci okula yeni
başlayan yanlış bölümü seçtiğini Düşünen
ve bir an evvel yol ayrımını çizmeye
çalışan bir genç bir öğrenci mutsuz
unsuz ve pişmanlıkları var
sonrasında karşısına çıkan bir fırsat
bir yarışma daveti için ekibe davet
ediyorlar ve o depresif haldeyken
vazgeçmiyor Şansını bir daha denemeye
çalışıyor emek veriyor sonrasında bir
başarı var bir yarışma başarısı var
sonrasında gelen yaz okulu sonrasında
İkisinden birleşiminden bir kazanç var
bir işe girme sonrasında daha iyi bir
işe girme ve sonrasında gelen bir teklif
para kulun hesabı yapmadan üniversitede
eğitim verme ve bunu yaparken de bir
şekilde kendi tarzını oluşturmak Emek
vermekten kaçmama sonrasında yüreğimi
sonrasında geleceği yazarlar sonrasında
BTK adayı ve son olarak da Microsoft
o zamanlar ki o zaman ki Ömer'e
sorsaydınız bu zamana Hayal edebiliyor
musun diye benim hayal gücümü çok
ötesindeydi kesinlikle Hayal edemezdim
Ama bu zamandan o zamana baktığımız
zaman da bu işi fitilleyen o işin
oralizm noktası da benim O bilgisayar
mühendisi bölümüne girmem Ve dahası o
yarışmaya girmem Bunların hepsi aslında
önemsiz şeyler gibi görünse de Küçük
Şeyler gibi görünse de benim bugün
sizlere karşısında anlatacak bir
hikayenin olmasını sağladım o yüzden
diyorum kendinizi keşfe Yani neyi
yapmaktan keyif aldığınızı keşfedin ki
hayatta size onun karşılığında güzel
şeyler versin beni dinlediğiniz için çok
teşekkür ediyorum harika
[Alkış]